Hannah if you're watching this I support
you and it's gonna be a rough go Buffalo
up but call me because I have your back
and honestly
Jesus still loves me you've talked about
the incredible backlash that you got yet
on the show being shamed being shamed
for your sexuality what do you think
Hannah has ahead for her based on what
we've seen is coming up I mean Jesus
might still love her but I'm not sure a
bachelor nation world I just want her to
like just call me Hannah call me look
like I will talk you through everything
the Internet is not kind to people who
women who talk about their sexuality
they're just not and it's what you have
to do is just know that it's I mean she
put it out there it's who you are and
you can't be ashamed of it and you just
have to stand by your decisions and and
who you are and and it'll all turn out
in the end the way it's supposed to
there's also unwritten rules this season
that are being crossed right when you're
as a cast member you understand
she's dating other guys you understand
when the fantasy suite comes around
there are three other people but an
unwritten rule is that when you're in
the relationship you talk about your
relationship and really don't get into
the weeds about some of the specifics
associated with what's going on in that
trailer we saw just the opposite of that
let's say you have had sex with one or
multiple of these guys I'd be wanting to
go home what's gonna be interesting to
me to see is who will get more backlash
for it Luke or Hannah we're in a time
where it's becoming more of a normal
conversation but in bachelor world it's
still so like faux pas - is that the
word for possum yeah - talk about it and
it's like it's such a gray area like
where is the line because it's like
people watch the show they know there's
fantasy suites they know there's sex
that goes on in the fantasy suites so
you guys are busy bees
yes living in Nashville together does it
feel like you're living together yet or
do you travel so much for working - all
these things that it hasn't sunk in yet
yeah I feel like we have been traveling
so much since I moved in that I'm like I
still need to unpack everything yeah so
the days we have had there have been
fantastic and we wake up with coffee and
we joke around we have this Power Hour
we sit down and like talk about business
things of what we have going on and
we'll
they're ending their night with a glass
of wine and I've enjoyed every minute of
it
yeah I mean are you ending your night
yes thank you
Oh peg way how great does it feel to
freaking have your own why honestly it
is a dream come true I'm not just saying
that it
since I had my first sip of wine ever in
life I was like like this is this is
what I'm supposed to be doing like
everything in my life has led me to have
a wine label this man everything it's
just like oh here we are
we have arrived
[Music]